and let's go tekken 5 boys
steve versus fang
this is a classic this is what i started
at but these characters were around like
this
i mean fang you know obviously got a ton
of buffs here in this uh in this stage
of uh tekken right the with the newest
patch steve always been super strong
always been super
annoying they didn't make it no more
annoying they called them [ __ ] bro
he does have some steve moves
oh i guess the down back three counter
hit
these are the buffs we're talking about
right oh it's only 12. oh but it gets
the peekaboo too as the homing attack
works out gets the wall too
saves the wall break the massage does
more damage anyways
oh it was in range yeah that's what i
was shocked about
oh keep the plus
wow down back one catches noelle out
there shao taking that first round the
spear of lubu
whoa
that is 14 decides not to punch it
i stuck
whoa
i don't like the usage of that yeah
really utilizing these big power moves
of fang oh backwards though that's all
he gets
falls up on the uh guaranteed hit with a
stomp on the damage
wow
playing this keep out game with the ford
four and the four four follow up noel
didn't bite yeah in the world basically
turning steve into just a straight whiff
punishing character right now and it's
doing work right now
and that's kind of the part with steve
right like sonic bang is fantastic for
the range and the speed but the damage
is not that scary so he's jealous kind
of like willing to whisk it there but
noel staying solid getting as many sonic
fang wood punches as you can get the
damage where you can buzzing for the low
ferry on the tenant justin
guess what there wow out of nowhere yeah
from downtown too
back campbell was good
punch perry set up no go get sidestepped
yeah noel's making shout with a lot
nice block dude
he's doing a lot of dances a lot of
forward four a lot of back tempo but now
he's not getting anything started
yeah it felt like like it feels like
he's still playing the same game but now
noel's just like all right i'll just
block it and whip punish yeah noel has
adjusted for sure
okay we got the guard break
of course looking forward to the hit
grounded
all the fish folk don't go nowhere
there's the back one free shoulder
oh it wasn't quite there not quite
enough
challenges with one two at a good time
oh yeah
he's willing to throw out that kenpo
step even from real close
oh this is so scary you know oh my god
trickery he's doing the fox step
backswing blow
on his life and he got the blue for blue
oh my god
what
oh my god that was so ballsy from shao
but he brought it back it's like one of
those things that's like man you
shouldn't be that confident to do the
between the legs you know slam dunk
while you're down 10 but it's like yeah
i was like
i'm doing 360 too don't worry about it
no scope
that's what he's playing around with he
got the lead now
finally in the lead in the set
yeah you tell that's kind of the way
shot likes to play right he likes the
whiff but try to catch noel running in
and it helped out the first couple
rounds but right now it's real real real
close a lot of this trickery yup coming
out of shell i love it the forward four
back here manual back turn just making
this really hard for uh noel to get in
and the back temples every once in a
while two mixed in look at that gets him
to burn the rage drive oh rocket
launcher finds himself
foreign
oh yeah he had to go and he went for the
mid mid noel didn't fight he was like
there's no mix it's a mid-high mix
there's no mix if i just stand block it
i wouldn't i would have ducked off
i would have duck that lost
that's it
that was so good that was that honestly
that that last situation at the end
there was pretty scary for both players
honestly but you know noel clutching it
out being able to take the take the
weight after getting pressured like that
so much right in that last round too it
felt like he was going to lose because
it just felt like
everything that xiao was doing was it
was hitting right every whiff was a set
up into something else but you know noel
played it cool played it slow and then
got the one pickup and that's all that
mattered so
good first game i really love that
mid-range game that xiao's playing it's
very
classic thing yeah yeah very classic
with forward fours get you to come in or
if the forward four tags you as you come
in it's a launcher it's really hard to
punish because that back turn keeps
himself safer and he can turn around by
down at all kinds of trickiness and
sometimes he does the manual one
sometimes he does bad campbell and it
just makes it really hard to like know
how to approach fang as a character it's
like if i overextend back campbell with
the hog kick is a real threat back
temple two into shoulder hurts you know
all that stuff hurts
you you see them back turn they're like
okay maybe i should extend here but
that's when you get hit by the sweep or
the back turn punches or something so
you know thank thanks for those
characters where even though he whiffs
it doesn't feel safe you know it's just
like you feel like you still have to
wait it out a little bit but
oh
all right it's game number two shout out
one game bringing it all the way back
with the fang
he's not scared about that campbell
stepped whether he's
whether he's a rage seven or range one
he's like
wow you did back keppel to forward tempo
with his face i love this
i'm not gonna hide there i guess the
size of four though
yeah willing to take that risk there the
side steps so good right just in order
just to create
great whiffs but then to be able to
sights of four hit a low that can launch
from close range is so so nice you have
to be really wary about it but if it
hits man you get part you get that's
what we're talking about
oh but gets the counter hit flicker two
this is gonna be big
that's just a lot all brakes do
what's the option here it goes for the
sonic fang running okey makes you feel
the
that's the worst dude everybody sound in
your mouth is like one of the worst
feelings in the entire world and it's
coarse it gets everywhere
round three all right tied up here
noelle
getting that first round in the second
game here
oh nice minnie mouse
caught him stepping or hitting a button
there back one two he's so plus that you
can't do anything
oh man pick it up oh
another flicker to counter and launcher
everything felt like a drop there but it
dropped into a counterhead launcher
every time
nice block on the people down too
wow
what a challenge with that backswing
blow after running too oh good block
though
that's the thing in this matchup right
it's just like uh yeah steve can't
launch down back three but the while
setting one two hurts that just eating
like two of those is almost like a
launch anyways
oh yes i'm with the frame trap he put
that one into the ten count
yep down back 3-2 to close it out there
noelle taking it 2-0 over shout out i
wouldn't say convincingly because it was
pretty scrambly it's pretty heavy but i
mean at the end there noel definitely
clutched it out right just played super
solid played very very safe and compact
and close it out so nice job
that's not going to be it for show
either he's going to have one more shot
at it in the loser's side but yeah i
liked a lot of his stuff seeing from